Rorty I'm sorry that stuff is alive and
it belongs with us we yanked them from
their homes and locked him in a can
mother see they're living in pain that's
what they do Rick they live in pain they
are pain you know they're all the bad
parts of us which by the way includes
our dishonesty so how do you know this
is an awesome sort of crazy trick oh so
now because I made entirely of toxins
I'm also a liar everybody knew Rick and
Morty let's break it down
grab your terry fold so there is a new
round of that merch giveaway - all you
have to do to enter just be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video so just a
start in Reverse a little bit you may
have spotted the Game of Thrones dig the
Adult Swim took at the end of the
episode but I think they only showed it
on TV so it was like a really brief
thing that only a portion of the
audience saw Justin roiland the other
creators Rick and Morty were going crazy
we didn't do this we had nothing to do
with throwing shade at Game of Thrones
so apparently somebody at Adult Swim
thought it would be funny to make a joke
about the writing on Game of Thrones
after the episode because the Game of
Thrones finale was this past Sunday
before the Rick and Morty episode so
r.i.p to whoever at Adult Swim was able
to get that on the air but the weird
thing about that is it's actually pretty
hard to get things on broadcast so it'll
be fun to see what the truth of that is
but you probably saw the cold-open back
at Comic Con that was sort of the Comic
Con teaser they released it just like
the entire thing it is a bit of a parody
of Star Wars
20 minute adventure you learned Jessica
and her friends are single again this
girl even looks exactly like big
stripper titties that summer was pissed
about in last week's episode who is just
going on and on about how she wants to
get peed on how she wants all this gross
stuff to happen to her so American
Psycho Morty missed out hardcore but I
guess the girlfriend that he ended up
finding at the end of the episode was
equally as twisted because she was
totally cool
with him being a little kid but there's
all kinds of visual references in this
cold open even though it technically
doesn't have a lot to do with the actual
story of the episode which is equally as
sexual there are a lot of sex jokes is
this a sex dungeon what's going on here
safe word is sea cucumber in a naked
Rick for like a pretty solid five
minutes of the episode almost but in the
quest to get this giant gem
20 minute adventure in-and-out Morty
they're being chased by these giant
sperm ships that look like they're
trying to fertilize this egg in the
middle of this giant space vagina
looking ship so it becomes this big
Return of the Jedi montage as they blow
up the Death Star here but it's this big
metaphor about having sex so they escape
the animations great on this and the
funny thing about Morty here is when he
screams it almost looks like they're
animating it to look a little bit like
the lemongrabs scream from adventure
time most of you probably know the
Justin roiland voice of Rick and Morty
one of the creators of the show also did
the voice for Lemongrab so every once in
a while he'll talk about lemongrab stuff
like where's all the Lemongrab merch
asking for a friend
but when they go to the day spa to chill
out that creature that eats them is
actually a spa for if you're not
familiar it's the shortened form of or
ophelia it's like the compulsion to
consume another person or another
creature be careful if you're gonna
search for stuff on the internet because
you will find some really twisted stuff
but Regis says they're taking advantage
of something that it would be doing
naturally it'd be like taking someone
with autism to Vegas who was really good
with numbers to count cards so
technically he's taking advantage of it
in a bad way
morally he's still classic Rick he
hasn't purged any of the bad parts of
himself so they purge themselves they
move on and we learn about the world of
the tank so the whole concept of this
episode the evil shadow self like the
toxic self was actually taken from
Wizard of Earthsea so if you're a big
fan of those novels that's what the
writers were going for it's where
someone has to confront their shadow
self but the big difference is that the
Earthsea novels are written about magic
so it's about this kid who's training to
be a mage but in trying to impress a
girl and getting in all kinds of fights
at school he raises this shadow demon
that he then has to face much later so
technically I would think the
protagonist and that is Rick because
Rick's the one that has the real
confrontation with his shadow self
American Psycho Morty really just tries
to avoid having to merge with his next
big gravity falls easter egg is actually
a really good one
actually makes sense based on the
episode that they pulled it from so in
the world of the tank you see like
basically everybody's toxic selves get
dumped so you have all this crap taken
from all these different people but you
actually spot eight-ball from the
weirdmageddon storyline on gravity falls
so the really cool thing about that if
you haven't seen those episodes in a
while it's actually a story arc from
gravity falls
we're basically bill tries to take over
the normal reality of gravity falls so
it's a bit like Rick from the tank toxic
Rick trying to take over the real world
bill tries to do the exact same thing in
eight-ball here is just part of his evil
group but they end up defeating him
later and then banished them all to
another dimension
so it's implied that eight-ball got
banished to the world of the tank
like in the world of gravity falls
there's an alternate dimension called
the mindscape so you can think of that
as sort of the path to the tank so for
all you conspiracy theorists that are
trying to prove that gravity falls is
just one of the alternate realities of
the Rick and Morty TV show this is just
more proof of that but they kind of
already proved that back in episode 1
with Mabel and dipper Morty so pretty
cool Easter Egg another good reason to
go back and watch that gravity falls
story arc 2 there weren't a whole lot of
Easter eggs in the fight montages where
you have toxic Rick vs. regular Rick you
just learned they're a lot of gadgets
hidden around the house so mental note
remembered that there's all these things
just hidden around in plain sight but
the funny thing here is that you look in
the background at the family photos and
Beth has taped a picture of a horse over
Jerry's head but I will say the American
Psycho Morty post-credit scene is
probably one of my favorite one because
the stuff that they're pulling from is
also really funny so you haven't seen
American Psycho it's a great Christian
Bale story the book is way more graphic
but it's just basically about this
person with zero conscience as Rick says
but when he's actually doing that stock
sale on the phone like when you actually
see him being a stockbroker the speech
they're pulling from is actually wolf of
wallstreet the Leonardo DiCaprio movie
which is equally as funny like the
character in that it just is ridiculous
but he's not quite as murderous as
American Psycho let me sum American
Psycho Morty he gets some crazy tail and
I'm not sure why they did this but they
turn Rick's drones into Voltron
maybe that was just like another funny
joke to add at the end of the episode
like on top of all this ridiculous stuff
that was happening but if you spotted
any more Easter eggs or references in
the episode just write them below in the
comments what's gonna happen is is
there's no new episode next week so the
next episode isn't for two weeks but
I'll still be doing some Rick and Morty
because Game of Thrones is done my
schedule is a little bit more free so
it'll be a little easier for me to post
Rick and Morty videos earlier like this
took me a little bit longer to get out
because of the big Game of Thrones
finale just to bring it back around to
that Rick and Morty Game of Thrones dig
which is technically an Adult Swim dig
not to throw the Rick and Morty people
under the bus but all that naked Rick
aside the episode was fantastic so let
me know favorite moment from the episode
like favorite joke that they did and
your favorite episode so far this season
I'm liking this episode a little bit
more than last week's episode which was
also one of my favorite of the season so
far
so new rick and morty posting later this
week i might have to do a gravity falls
easter egg montage at some point because
almost every episode not quite every
episode but almost they have a gravity
falls reference so we'll say
congratulations to the latest merch
giveaway sigma gaming please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so i can get your contact details you
can click here for more rick and morty
and you can click here for brand new
game of thrones thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome i'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]